weil sie nicht also ich komm doch wenn
ich die nacht durchgemacht habe ich
komme dann noch park klar menschliches
sowie mein gehirn er sonst im kanal und
daniela minecraft spielen christian
beeck eltern herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video im real life und zwar
ein video 20 fakten oder mich nicht so
ausgesucht habe die ich euch sagen
wollte so paar sachen halt über mich so
was ich mag was ich nicht so mag was so
ein paar eigenschaften von mir sind usw
und ja es ist in rio dachte hey komm ich
dann auch eigentlich mal wieder ein
bisschen rudolf machen weil ich das
jetzt noch nicht gemacht habe und das
video wo ich gesagt okay ich mache keine
basecape habe ich auch gesagt dass
eventuell bald wieder ein bisschen mehr
geld kommt ich muss ein bisschen rum
backen weil vorhin ich hab schon das
beste steak glaube ich mittlerweile weil
die ganze zeit meine kameramann hey du
bewegst dich ja gar nicht ob ich mein
vati mobile aufnahme und ja fick dich
kamera befinden kann direkt an mit der
ersten sache immer wenn ich mir die
zähne putze bzw
bevor sie nur kurz bevor ich mir die
zähne putzt bevor ich mir das ding in
münchen ein spaß ist es immer so dass
ich die zahnbürste erst nachts mache
dann zahlen wir dann noch mal das macht
also macht ihm die zwei mal dass ich
weiß nicht ob stelle ein sie gewinnen
oder ob das bei euch halt auch so ist
aber dann könnt ihr mir einfach in die
kontakte können jetzt mit nahezu jedem
festschreiben was ihr davon haltet und
papier das auch so macht oder ob mir das
irgendwie anders macht und sollte das
könnten jetzt mal einfach unten
beschreiben zwei effekt also ein platz
frei bleiben sobald die zweite sache ist
ich brauche mal jahre zum einschlafen
also egal ob es am wochenende ist es
nicht so aber in der schulzeit weil ich
immer so abgefragten schlafrhythmus am
wochenende das ist so heftig weil ich am
wochenende wenn man in die freiheit ist
oder so ist man um 4 uhr zu hause oder
halb fünf oder so dann liege ich da im
bett und pentium 5 1 und dann mache ich
am nächsten tag um 13 uhr auf oder 14
oder zum 2 0 damit hast und ich bin
immer noch müde und dann ist dann
meistens wenn man samstag
ein weißes dann sonntag und du bist dann
abends so hyperaktiv wie ein stück
scheiße alter bloß beispiel sowie partie
die sollen löwe auf krank oder in die
sauce ist so heftig sonne verfügten
schlafe ich werd ich brauche meine zum
einschlafen also ich wirklich ja ich
habe jetzt zwei jahre zu schaffen
braucht das war so heftig also die
dritte sache ist ich komme damit nicht
klar mit messer und gabel in die also
ich kann ganz normal essen und ich kann
auch mit messer rechts und links also
für euch ist dass gerade in dirty
woanders aber immer wenn ich jetzt hier
zum beispiel wenn ich manchmal wenn ich
esse eigentlich macht mir immer besser
rechts und gerade links ich vertrau
stadt verläuft einfach also ich dir doch
dann so rum und lässt und so weiter und
dadurch wiederum 30 so weiter also ich
weiß nicht wie er das macht also können
wir auch einen ausschlag für mich hat
sich das einfach so ist meine eltern mir
beigebracht dass ich so links und messer
rechts aber ich weiß nicht ich wette
dass niemand kann damit nicht so gut
klar
keine ahnung vierte sache ist sehr viele
leute mögen pilze ich mag gar keine art
von pilzen scheiß egal welche ich mal
gar keine
allerdings mögen sehr viele leute spinat
nicht und ich mag spinat einfach ich
liebe spieler hatte ich mache jetzt
nichts plötzlich in china waren könnt
und also habe ich mag spinat und viele
jugendliche oder als allgemein läuft
sagt blätter mit scheiße aber eben diese
nicht also ich mag keine pilze aber
dafür mag ich
fakt über mich 5 ich sage meine meinung
immer laut also nicht das was ich denke
ich immer lauten ich denke laut uba das
natürlich nicht sondern immer wenn ich
wirklich eine meinung habe und die
anderen
meinung dann gesagt ich halte meine
meinung oder das ist auch in der schule
immer so aber wird die an allem was
sagen zum beispiel ein
religionsunterricht kann man das gut
beobachten wenn die esa zwar die
weltreligionen gewesen aber es ist halt
so
weil religion halt einfach so einfach
ist wenn meine eigene meinung
präsentieren kann wenn alle haben und
zum beispiel sagen ja auch sigmund freud
beste religionskritik dann sage ich ich
sag immer meine meinung gesagt jetzt
ohne kat weiter und zwar ich dusche
immer mindestens 10
es ist einfach so auf wenn irgendwie
fußball ist oder soll ich bestimme zehn
minuten weil ich jeden unter der dusche
und ich denke einfach nur die ganze zeit
über mein leben nach ich denke nach was
werde ich jetzt als nächstes machen ich
denke mal nach was für euch bei youtube
machen was wir später hinziehen also
dass ich natürlich ist alles geklärt
aber darüber denke ich denn was oma und
ihr könnt ja eigentlich noch ihre zeit
stoppen einfach so wenn ihr mit
bestimmte handy mit obskuren vor dem
duschen oder wenn ich mir jahre führt
oder so ich bin immer handys und
facebook im durchschnitt handy könnte ja
mal fand die zeit stoppt und mir das
auch eine kommentare schreiben wir auf
den passierte so die siebte sache ist
ich habe erst zwei mal die nacht
durchgemacht
das ist einfach das erste mal mitgemacht
und dachte hey ich war 13 oder sogar
nachts durch aco danach war mein schlaf
rhythmus liebe zu einer zwei wochen lang
danach ein zwei jahre später war noch
sondern an und haben dann auch eine
nacht durchgemacht und danach jung ich
kam nicht mehr klar ich konnte nicht
mehr schlafen tagsüber miene wie sonst
aus den abends hyperaktiv und das ist
einfach ich kann es natürlich machen und
keine ahnung aber danach ich liebe
meinen schlaf einfach über alles und
deswegen weil sie nicht also ich komme
nach wenn ich die nacht durchgemacht
habe ich komme dann noch gar nicht klar
mein status ist so wie man ihn sonst
immer ja und damit kommen eigentlich
auch schon zu achten sache und zwei ich
liebe meinen schlaf es gilt ins westbad
so die leute sache ist wahrscheinlich
die wo viele leute darüber nachdenken
und das so wollen aber ist später keiner
umsetzen kann bzw
jetzt wird weil sie dann in meinem land
und zwar die erste wohnung die erste
eigene wohnung
für mich soll die extrem glatt sein also
andere sagen ich auch bett und eine
küche und ein fernseher das war es 20
quadratmeter oder so also ich sag das
schon sehr erste wohnung 80 quadratmeter
mindestens schön gelegen
mindestens bis 2005 oder so also sollte
auf jeden fall eine schöne wohnung seine
moderne schöne wohnung und nicht die
welt auch ein später mit und freund nach
düsseldorf und macht man da von zwei
jahren die gangway bum bum bum kommt
natürlich auch einen router aber die
ersten bäume sollten auf jeden fall
schön sind also die solchen fall richtig
geil wenn du nicht einfach nur seinen
sonnborn bord werfen und studiert
zehntes ich immer zur vorfreude egal ob
das egal der diego feiern die und cooles
event ist oder ob ich zum beispiel in
freizeitparks war das erste mal diesem
freitag
und ich dachte offiziell achterbahn vor
heftig sich fliegt aber schon verkauft
und 250 und weiß nicht ob ihm wie immer
zu hohen vorfreude halbes gibt und wir
können nicht weitermachen
das einzige was ich auf irgendwelchen
langen fahrten brauche das ist mir
aufgefallen weil ich in letzter zeit
sehr viel zug fahre sei es ihm nach köln
hätten seinen charakter freunde besuchen
sei es in urlaub fahren weg stunden
ich brauche nur mein handy ich brauche
mein handy und die einzeln jetzt
brauchst whatsapp facebook und spotify
einfach musik und nebenbei den leuten
chatten mehr brauche ich eigentlich gar
nicht also ich weiß nicht wie leute die
sich dann kommt und was zu fressen und
so was alles ich kaufen einfach an den
haltestationen subways allen wünschen
flasche wasser mehr in die wir das was
wir wollten wenig zwölfter
ich bin übel schnellen bearbeiten von
videos also sei es egal was ich hab alle
griffe im video auch bei premiere cs
einfach
zu packen das jetzt hier auch an einer
stelle zähler ist kabel sachen steuerung
zählten papiere ich das dann letztlich
nach anfang intro draufziehen musik
runterziehen musik immer audio frequency
of - 26
meine stimme immer noch was kompressor
weinen so was alles also ich weiß die
ganzen griffe auswendig weiß genau wenn
ich was die premiere ein ziel zum
beispiel dieses megaprojekt 30 minuten
folge ich brauche zwei minuten zum
bearbeiten mit musik und alles rennt
dann braucht er natürlich reif ist
kreativ erstellt das liegt an meinem pc
aber ich kann das einfach riebel schnell
als ich weiß nicht mal wie man ok
gespielt
er braucht man bislang als hatte mir
letztes mal gesagt und ich weiß nicht
also ich habe alle griffe irgendwie
drauf und bei mir das durch wie wenn du
deinem oder durchfall hat 13 ist eine
sache die läuft jeder von uns hatte dass
man es sehr viele ich habe damals so
viele pokémon partie gesagt ich hab mir
ganz der diese verfügten strafe gestellt
und ich wusste nicht wie das spiel geht
ich hatte da das antlitz des tools oder
so ich muss nicht wieder spiele und ich
bin einfach so blöd ich habe mir nie
anleitungen im internet durch gelesen
ich habe etwa die daten gesammelt
ich wusste nicht das perfekte spiel gilt
ich habe nur diese scheiß karten
gesammelt
das war gegen kopf klar schiff geld
dafür aus 14
ich hasse meinen kräften spaß also ich
mag vanilla minecraft ihn gar nicht
verdienen ist jetzt megabyte und vita
liest ich will dass wir nie mehr spiel
nicht deswegen das ist auch der grund
warum ich kein let's play mache was
einfach so in vanilla minecraft ist das
würde ich nicht durchhalten das färben
885 folgen finde ich das so unfassbar
langweilig weil ich brauchte ihn wie
technik sachen oder neue items die
herausfinden kann oder muss vorstellen
oder sie zwar steht natürlich alles aber
das ist dann auch nicht so eines pay
oder so was also ich keine ahnung
vanilla minecraft spielen 15 ist ich
habe schon alle mainstream sportarten
durch ich habe damals 34
ich glaube vier jahre tennis gespielt
zwei jahre basketball und dann
sechs jahren fußball oder so also ich
habe schon alle menschen in sportarten
wie durch die es in deutschland gibt
das nenne ich drei monaten oder napster
in verbindung mit dieser sache die ich
gerade gesagt hab also dass sich in
allen sportarten durchhalten kann man
auch zur fußball neuer verbinden sagen
dass ich bayern fan seit ich neun bin
also haltet euren schmerz mit erfolg
wenn ich bin die ganzen schlechten
zeiten durchgegangen und die kurzzeitig
auf platz 16 standen und ich bin auch
die zeiten durchgegangen wurde im
europapokal planen und dann gegen sankt
petersburg 41 ausgeschieden sind und so
was alles also ich weiß alles über den
verein und erfolgsfans sind für mich
einfach leute die sofort ihren verein
wechseln auch wenn damals schlechten
zeiten ist und ich war immer bei
anfällen und alle die jetzt dort gefällt
sind und seit jahren oder seit 23 jahren
verfolgt werden kann ich auch zu sagen
weil dort die letzten also vor 32 jahren
über es gut wird die am übels viele
reizvoll bekommen und viele neue fans
also auch erfolgs wenn man ist kein
erfolg wenn du beim ein fan von bayern
ist dass ich verstehe das nicht wo ist
die logik ich hasse es ganz einfach also
fast 17 ich mag es einfach überhaupt
nicht viele denken auseinanderbrechen
als würde ich meine ich finde style ganz
es geht
es geht aber ich liebe das jetzt nicht
so wie alle anderen und ich habe auch
ein foto bei instagram gebrauchte
tierpark da ein gewinn ist übrigens
instagram wird kommst du schlägst du
kannst doch unten immerhin der
beschreibung könnte mal vorbeischauen
habe ich ein bild gepostet nur spaghetti
mit scampis mann und ich hab nur
spaghetti gegessen und die scouts waren
das einzige tor an
also ich mache das ganze ich weiß nicht
keine ahnung welches behindert
fakt 18 ich bin ps3 kind da unten
gesehen als ich komme auf jeden
europäers 4
und welch eine xbox ist die zusammen
schlagen als ich war im urlaub mit
freundin mit max mit dem ich hier
facebook wieder da gemacht habe und die
hatten die xbox mittelalterlich ich bin
überhaupt nicht klar gekommen auch wenn
es das gleiche spiel war so viel
vertrauen oder black ops 2 ich bin so
nicht klar gekommen ich will kann
einfach nur ps3 und ich komme einfach
mit diesen controller und gleich kommen
nur mit denen klar ich weiß wie ich kann
nicht mit anderen controllern tricks
kann fakt 19 ich hasse stimmen vor
geräusche alter wenn man so einen
styropor ab und man geht damit den zehn
andere berichten coach kind sterben ich
will ich glaube wenn man nicht foltern
würde man müssen wir nun steuerbord
jemanden der die ganze zeit so drüber
kratzt oder toshiba styroporplatte
styroporplatte so kommen wir zum letzten
fest ich muss eben ein handy entsperren
ich antworte bei goebbels oft mit
smileys wie zum beispiel angela merkel
steht sagt zu warmer bruder oft bei dir
oder haftbefehl leben wie soja junge
class bruders oder sowas oder irgendwie
so ein tor fällt so oder so ich schicke
einfach manchmal wenn wir leute
nachrichten senden
ich antworte mit zu zweit ist einfach
oder zum beispiel so wenn einer mit
semmel sagte hey guck mal hier das essen
das macht ein eps von 2 tb sonntag vor
seinem pc sitzt und erst guckt also auf
den pc man guckt er so in das bild und
er macht einfach keinen regen also ich
liebe solches weil ich einfach das
wissen auch alle freunde von mir die das
gerade gucken mit denen ich das
beschreiben die wissen dass des übels
gerne mache video mit dem video ich weiß
mein handy offenbarte das scheiße zu
machen sondern das was mal wieder mit
einem rededuell könnte weitere
vorschläge in die kommentare schreiben
es wird wahrscheinlich mal wieder bald
face cancom und was alles und ich muss
jetzt weiter in den spenden streamen und
dann wollte ich auch selber streamen
irgendwann am abend noch und ich liebe
euch alle